[Music]
[Applause]
i think it's been six weeks since we had
carson palmer on that was uh during
super bowl week
had him during the regular season always
appreciated his insights certainly at
the quarterbacking position the former
heisman trophy winner at usc are you a
former heisman trophy winner or you're
just a heisman trophy winner
yeah i think you get rid of the former
part and just keep it heisman trophy
winner sounds better okay so former nfl
quarterback heisman trophy winner
perfect okay perfect all right so
of all the things that have happened
since the super bowl what's the number
one thing that stood out to you good or
bad
but i think the biggest story is aaron
rodgers went back to green bay on on a
new contract i mean that was the
the headline throughout the season
obviously last year this time and then
last year this time all the way up
through training camp before the season
started
um but him back in green bay still
wearing the green and yellow i think um
it's it's the best for the nfl it's the
best for aaron it's the best obviously
for the packers and packer fans
themselves
you got the situation with the browns
where it feels like baker mayfield may
have talked himself out of a job and
that city and they bring in deshaun
watson
um let me start with baker mayfield what
kind of
trade market do you think there is for
baker mayfield going into the last year
of his contract coming off the injury
well there's there's definitely a market
for it it's not the three or four first
round picks or two firsts and two
seconds or whatever it is that that the
cleveland browns had to give to the the
houston texans to get deshawn watson
it's definitely they're not going to get
their money back on that but there's
there's somebody out there there's too
many teams that need a quarterback and
baker is a much better upgrade
than a lot of the guys that these these
teams have on their rosters so there's
there's a market for him but
unfortunately right now
you know this is that time
we should be talking about baker's next
deal with the browns they're negotiating
it they're still kind of in that
honeymoon phase they only took them
with the first pick in the draft a
couple years ago we should be talking
about that we should not be talking
about the friction between baker and the
browns and this kind of constant theme
that has been going on for a couple off
seasons now
but i i do i do think there is somebody
out there that's willing to give up
something to get bigger okay but if i
said to you you could have matt ryan or
baker mayfield in indianapolis
i'd take
because of the situation that
indianapolis colts are in right now
they've got a veteran team they're one
player away from being a contender i
take matt ryan
yeah i could see him going into that
matthew stafford role he's a couple
years older than matthew but i think
that he's he's ready to go
the role that jimmy garoppolo plays in
all of this with the musical chairs with
quarterbacks is what
he'll be somewhere i mean i think um the
niners are waiting out post-draft to let
teams really realize there aren't that
many good quarterbacks in this draft we
need a vet
he'll go somewhere and he'll
i think he'll actually drum up more
demand than what baker will get as far
as what the team's going to get in
return for a trade but there's
definitely a market for jimmy garoppolo
is there any football concerns are there
any football concerns about deshawn
watson just as a player just as a
quarterback
zero
zero i think
um he's you know within the top five
best players in the league uh he he
changes your team instantly he brings a
level of confidence to your team
instantly
uh you know i know there's there's
obviously a lot of guys that love
playing with baker and have a tremendous
amount of respect i've seen some quotes
about the warrior that he was and
playing injured and playing through the
shoulder and all that he played through
but desean's the same type of player you
know he puts it on the field
uh you get everything he's got uh you
get it you get it from him on a daily
basis on a weekly basis
throughout the season i think deshawn's
gonna have a great year you combine
deshawn with those two running backs
that pass rush they have there in
cleveland the opportune opportunistic
defense on the back end that can get
picks and get him the ball back and more
importantly something desean has not had
an offensive line like the cleveland
browns since he got into the league so
seeing desean play with that group in
front of him in cleveland is going to be
something new that we haven't seen him
play with at this level how many massage
therapists did you have when you were
playing
just one just one my gay my guy dave
matthews in phoenix he's the best in the
business
actually works on a number of nfl guys
but if you find you know massage
therapists are like anything there's a
bunch of them
and only a very few select hand you know
you know top one percent are really
gifted and talented and have been given
a god-given ability uh so when you find
that guy i think we've heard russell
wilson has found you know found his and
spends a lot of money on on his guy
um but finding the right guy that can
keep you together tom brady with alex
guerrero for all the years he's been
he's been playing finding that right
right guy is priceless yeah i've said
that before i i mentioned in the first
hour of the show i have somebody who
played 13 years and played somebody else
played nine and i said how many massage
therapists and they both said one if you
find the one that's why you have a a
serial pattern here with desean watson
you don't have 22 and you're not finding
them on instagram
yeah i mean i i don't know exactly what
went on there um i don't know that we
all will or we all will for a little
while you know until he gets cleared
that he's he's able to play all 17 games
for the cleveland browns there's no
suspensions until we start hearing that
chatter we don't know where that
situation is i haven't had yawn since uh
you know your cardinals there with kyler
murray uh
is everything good with your your
cardinals here and his demands
i think everything will be good when he
signs his next contract but until that
time i mean there's you know it's been a
tumultuous offseason for the for the
cardinals and for kyler obviously as
this story is unfolded but the chatter
that's quieted down i think is a good
sign i think it means they're making
some headway on a new contract or
they've got some sort of agreement in
place verbally when they will get to
that contract discussion so the fact
that it's been quiet all quiet on that
front is probably a good thing for the
cards
i said at the time and i'd firmly
believe it that the chiefs got a deal a
bargain with patrick mahomes contract
like once
in in three or four years like what are
quarterbacks going to be making and
mahomes that's going to be a bargain
yeah well that's the problem and that's
why you've seen aaron consistently sign
shorter term deals because he knows
every three or four years once that
guaranteed money is paid out on that
portion of the contract that he's up for
a new one that's the problem with a guy
like mahomes and like to your point the
chiefs did the right thing by giving him
a longer term deal more duration more
years if they would have given him a
shorter deal which he would have
preferred and the chiefs not preferred
he'd be up for renegotiation probably
after this season but the longer the
deal you sign that day you sign it it
looks really sexy and it looks really
good but when it's a seven
eight nine year deal once you get
halfway through it you're underpaid
carson wentz going to the commanders
um have they found their quarterback
no no i think it's a you know it's a
stop gap for them they're still
searching i feel like
you know you think back to those early
days of rg3 and then kurt cousins and
then kirk cousins wasn't good enough for
him but they kept paying him with the
you know they kept tagging him and
tagging him and then he was on to a new
team and they got nothing for him it
just doesn't seem like they know what
they're doing uh from from the
quarterback position i mean it's been a
constant search not that the search is
easy but again
you just saw the indianapolis colts go
through it i mean
and the commanders are in the same
situation they've got a good offensive
line they've got a good defense they've
got some really nice pieces and they're
a quarterback away
but the the colts just showed you what
you shouldn't do is is take on a
one-year contract or a two-year contract
for a guy that you know has not played
well or played up to his potential in
years and i think we're going to see the
same thing shake out in washington that
we saw shake out this past season in
indy i got you two and a half years
younger than tom brady and here he is
coming back carson what was your
reaction
i i don't think you can be surprised
with anything that happens with brady um
you know i i never really bought into
the retirement thing because you didn't
officially see him say it or really see
any real response from him on it
um but he's he's a modern marvel i mean
the guy keeps doing it i cannot imagine
i woke up this morning early before the
show to get a workout in and i cannot
imagine
waking up early to get my workout on and
get getting prepared for next season at
my age let alone at 44. yeah if i gave
you six months to get ready
to play to play in one game or play in
17
how about one
i could get through the first half
but once i got into the locker room
and my body had a chance to cool down
and i had i sat down and you know in
front of in front of my locker on the
bench i'd have a tough time getting back
up to head out to the stadium for the
third quarter uh i know you do uh some
great things that uh maybe people aren't
aware of you're involved in camp rainbow
gold uh give you the opportunity to talk
about how special that place is to you
yeah i'm really excited to be the
spokesperson for camp rainbow gold it's
a camp in idaho uh where kids from all
over the state with cancer can can trade
in and get out of the hospital that
they've been
living in uh and get out of those bright
lights of a hospital get outside go to
summer camp like like a normal kid their
age
the camp is full of
all people donating their time the camp
counselors the doctors that come in to
administer chemotherapy uh to do
checkups so it's an amazing place in
fairfield idaho um
you can learn more about it on camp
rainbowgold.org
but at the end of the day it's a
beautiful special place where kids with
cancer that haven't had their fair shake
at life or their families their siblings
their mom and dad
that have been living in a hospital with
them can get out and be a normal kid and
go to summer camp
so it's a great organization i'm really
proud to be a part of it uh and you can
learn more again on camp rainbowgold.org
great to talk to you as always carson
thanks for joining us
thanks dan carson palmer heisman trophy
winner former nfl quarterback